so you did the thing everyone told you not to
do and now you've messed up your skin barrier
maybe you exfoliated too much maybe you started
too many irritating ingredients at the same time
maybe you've had a cold and you've rubbed
your nose too hard and now your skin's red
and flaky weirdly shiny it's textured
your pores are more obvious you've got
more breakouts and the most telltale sign of
all products that don't normally sting are
stinging maybe even water is stinging here
is a step-by-step guide on how to fix it
this video is sponsored by bondi sands i'll be
using some of the products from their everyday
skincare range as examples their products are
perfect for dealing with this situation and
not getting into it in the first place
step one stop using irritating products let's
go back and understand what you did and what's
happening to your skin basically your skin has
10 to 20 layers of dead cells on top this is
the stratum corneum often referred to as your
skin barrier the cells in this barrier are dead
but that doesn't mean they don't have an important
function they act as a barrier between your living
cells and the outside world so this stratum
corneum keeps water from evaporating there are
lots of important processes going on inside your
skin that require enough water to work water keeps
your skin supple and flexible and it stops it from
cracking the stratum corneum also keeps irritants
and germs out this is its main function it acts
as a form of protection for the rest of your skin
if you exfoliate too much you end up with a
thinner stratum corneum with less layers it's
like you're giving yourself a mild chemical burn
your barrier ends up weaker and less effective
than it used to be so now things that didn't used
to irritate now might actually irritate with this
lesser protection so the first thing to do is
to stop sanding back what barrier you have left
so stop using exfoliating products and the faster
you stop the faster you'll recover it can take
months if you're really unlucky and you've been
ignoring all of the signs so here are some of
the things you need to stop using firstly chemical
exfoliants this includes alpha hydroxy acids like
glycolic acid and lactic acid also beta hydroxy
acid also known as salicylic acid also check the
ingredients of your toners as well sometimes
they're not labeled as chemical exfoliants but
they still have these ingredients in them you also
need to stop using physical exfoliants the obvious
ones to look out for are scrubs and peeling gels
but you might also want to check other things such
as your towels your cloths and pillowcases
if they're a bit rough they can act like
physical exfoliants and buff away your dead skin
cells there's also shaving if you shave you are
actually taking off some dead skin cells when you
pass the razor over your face you'll want to be
really careful with this as your skin is trying to
recover also look out for enzyme exfoliants this
includes papaya and pineapple enzymes sometimes
these are in products that are labeled glow
on top of this you'll also need to stop other
irritating products you might be using your
skin has the ability to repair itself but if you
keep attacking it it can't do that unfortunately
this includes most of the active ingredients that
people hype up in skin care you'll want to stop
using retinoids these are vitamin a derivatives
like retinol retinaldehyde and granactive retinoid
which are found in regular cosmetic products you
might also want to put a pause on some of the
ones in prescription products like tretinoin
and adaptolene other common ingredients you
might want to stop are ascorbic acid the classic
form of vitamin c and kojic acid which is a skin
lightening ingredient if you have products with
heavy fragrance that can also irritate your skin
now that you've paused most of your regular
skincare routine we're up to step two which is
use bland products at this point you don't want to
add irritating products into your routine you need
to give your skin a break but hydrated skin does
heal better and it helps your skin protect itself
so it's important to pick products that
your skin is less likely to react to
i'd recommend using different products depending
on what stage of your healing you're at
at the start you'll probably want to use
more oil based and thicker products and
that's because some water-based products can sting
your skin when it's in this very vulnerable state
an example of a product i'd recommend is the
wonder potion from bondi sands this is a mix
of really nice nourishing oils you can also use
a thicker balm product if you're after something
a little lighter that you can wear during the
day and it won't look too greasy bondi sands
have released two fragrance-free moisturizers
these both have a really beautiful texture they
sink into your skin and they protect your skin
and hydrate it without being shiny and greasy
and so they work really well during the day
under makeup or even just under sunscreen
again hydrating products can sometimes make
your skin a little bit more irritated they can
make your skin barrier more permeable so if your
barrier is already pretty compromised water-based
products tend to sting more this isn't necessarily
bad but it's not very comfortable so i'd recommend
adding hydrating toners a little bit further down
the line when your skin is a bit more resilient
step three is to use repairing products now you
need to be really really cautious but your skin
can benefit from adding products with repairing
actives one of these ingredients is niacinamide
bondi sands has the begin again serum which has
ten percent niacinamide with one percent zinc
the bondi sand serums are in
this really great packaging
it's a lot easier to deal with than a glass
dropper bottle it's much more travel friendly
it's spill proof it's made from recycled material
and it is recyclable the serum itself has a
thicker texture than a lot of other niacinamide
products on the market so it's a lot easier to
apply but it still spreads really nicely on
the skin there are also some soothing plant
extracts that can help so you might want
to look out for chamomile and oatmeal as
well as centella asiatica extract sometimes this
shows up in the ingredients list as one of these
now step four is to start again really slowly once
your skin has stopped stinging as much it's gotten
a bit more resilient and it's recovered you can
start again with your skincare routine now you
need to be super cautious your skin might not
be as recovered as you think and you don't want
to have to go through this whole process again
so i recommend using really gentle products to
start with don't start off again with once a week
peels or double digit concentration exfoliants or
one percent retinol as you have now experienced it
can take weeks or months to recover so you want to
have patience going in so for example you want
to start off with low concentrations don't use
high concentrations just for the sake of higher
concentrations like i said in a previous video it
is a myth that higher concentrations are always
better one product i really love from the bondi
sands range is the buff and polish chemical
exfoliant this is a really gentle product
it uses gentler ingredients like lactic acid and
gluconolactone these ingredients are a bit larger
and so their molecules don't get into the skin as
quickly as glycolic acid so this cuts down on any
potential irritation by a lot with any product
you should try to introduce it really slowly
there are lots of different ways of doing this so
firstly you can try using less you can measure out
your product on your hand and dilute it with
a different product like a moisturizer to help
it spread you should also start off by using the
product less often so use it every couple of days
instead of every single day at first when you're
starting you can also wash off the product after
five minutes instead of leaving it overnight
and so that cuts down the contact time between
the ingredient and your skin also make sure when
you're using irritating products that the rest
of your products are very gentle so use things
with moisturizers and soothing products also
use things with gentle cleansers the bondi sands
fresh'n up cleanser is a really gentle fragrance
free low foaming cleanser it's really hydrating
and it cleans your skin without stripping it
so like and subscribe to promise you'll
be nicer to your skin and let me know any
other barrier repair tips you might have in the
comments i did a video talking about the bondi
sands everyday skincare range for the channel
check it out via the link in the description